[Music]
here's a look at Austin Texas this
morning where a very accomplished 8th
grader is the country's new Geography
Bee champion Nihar Jenga beat out 53
other state and territory champions to
win that title yesterday making him an
incredible double champion Jen Crawford
was there to see it Jen good morning
good morning Anthony so ok here again is
this year's winning a question more than
1/3 of Norway's northernmost County is
located on which Plateau who knew Norway
had a plateau
well now hard jenga he was all over it
here is the dramatic finale with CBS
Sunday mornings Mo Rocca NER what you
have the Finnmark plateau a tray of what
you have for danger Vito the correct
answer is the Finnmark plateau
[Applause]
until the final moment harsh anga felt
like the underdog as the final round of
the championships went into overtime the
two finalists tied for five rounds in a
row and the answer is the Red Sea but
Jenga had felt this kind of pressure
before back in 2016 he was the coach
champion of the Scripps National
Spelling Bee in the moment that his hard
work paid off for a second time he was
overwhelmed all this is over all the
pressure from studying is after making
the top ten at last year's Geography Bee
jenga's father wanted him to retire and
would focus on school that plan paid off
now janga is setting his sights even
higher hoping to compete in the
International brain beat as a high
schooler what do you have any idea what
you might want to be when you grow up a
neurosurgeon that was my guess but you
know in the teen category of the
competition for 10 year olds from New
York took home first place they wowed
the judges with the river filtration
system to remove plastic before it
reaches the ocean microplastics then
worked their way into the food chain and
eventually to us they're using the prize
money to implement their solution these
problems because we share one bigger now
that winning team that you just saw
there took home $25,000 to put toward
their project they're not spending on
video games they're gonna put it to good
use and Django won a 25 thousand dollar
college scholarship because of this
year's success with that challenge that
focused on plastic pollution National
Geographic said it's going to continue
that theme next year Tony this guy could
go to jeopardy as far as what are you
gonna do with those you're gonna do
anything you want when you grow up yeah